I don't pretend to have all the answers
believe me I am still learning all the
time but in some quiet moment today or
in the days to come
imagine the conversation you might have
with your future self think about the
path you'll take to get there
I'm not just talking about the career
choices you make but rather the way you
walk that path the values you live the
qualities you embody the example you set
even when nobody's watching it's the
most important thing the right thing to
know what he's watching well that's noir
of course delivering the commencement
address last night at Kane university's
graduate college ceremony in New Jersey
she shared her own note to self about
the importance of listening and allowing
your setbacks to make you stronger Cain
gave Nords Medal of Honor the highest
award it bestows on any individual where
we gonna say Charlie congratulations and
that's a very important lesson look
forward to the end of your life and see
what you want people to be saying about
you and you start doing that today yeah
what's that